battle rap award words using intricate
schemes raw syncopated delivery
and witty wordplay
Lyricist turned the art of rap into a
Clash of the Titans Now on the half the
crowd swinging from these bars I ain't
with the monkey business I like that
movie I can check back
over the years battle rap has expanded
from the hip-hop underground and into
mainstream pop culture whether it's m
M's Eight Mile Netflix's Rhythm and flow
James corden's dropped the mic or the
epic rap battles of history on YouTube
today battle rap is a professional sport
with Superstar athletes and leagues all
around the world and one of the most
popular leagues is the ultimate rap
League or URL for sure we all together
basically organize the culture and just
made a business out of it really making
an intern in this whole art form into a
league for over a decade the URL has
drawn over 650 million views on YouTube
and provided viral battle rap moments
consider it an art form because
um the fact that these guys go up there
and put on the show right it's all
theater it's all performing in arts
right so where did battle rap come from
and how did it become so popular across
the world this is the story of how
battle rap evolved from underground
competitions to the global streaming
phenomenon it is today
[Music]
I've been a battle rap fan for a long
time for years I followed the culture on
YouTube watching my favorite battle is
how I watch my favorite drummers or
basketball players but I've always
wondered how battle rap got its start so
let's get into it the art of spoken word
has been around since ancient times for
centuries grios from West Africa have
recounted Tribal history to their
communities through music and poetry in
the West Indies Calypso artists have
engaged in pecan duels where singers
fire rhyming insults at each other in
song
candidly
[Music]
stopping it back and smile because you
have a face like
American culture young people play the
dozens a verbal game where people take
turns lobbing humorous insults at each
other in front of an audience but battle
rap as we know it today didn't start
until the 1980s
in the early 80s hip-hop collectives
attended conventions to compete against
each other for prize money and bragging
rights at first these competitions were
friendly face-offs to prove which crew
could do a better job at rocking the
crowd that was until the Christmas
rappers contest at the Harlem World Club
in 1981. that's when a battle between
Kumo D and Busy Bee Starsky changed how
MC's approached rap competition forever
busy Beast claimed that he would knock
out all bombs before the contest was not
taken well by Kool Modi determined to
make a point
entered the contest after basically
finished his set and rocked the crowd
with a verse that directly attacked
vizini's credibility as a rapper
on hold
these rhyming disses inspired other MCS
to adopt his style and engage in small
rap battles at basketball courts and
corner stores around New York this style
helped move the genre away from the old
school upbeat party themed hip-hop into
a grittier art that showcased lyrical
ability Roxanne Shantae was among the
first female battle rappers in the 80s
and a rap beef Pioneer starting the
Roxanne war with her Infamous diss track
Roxanne's revenge in 1984.
[Music]
as hip-hop entered the 90s the tradition
of calling out your peers on record
continued influencing several Infamous
rap thiefs memorable conflicts between
artists like Ice Cube and common Dr Dre
and Uncle Luke Tupac and Biggie and most
notably the exchange between Jay-Z and
Nas have been etched into hip-hop
history
[Music]
talk about me laugh behind my back but
in my face shot some well-wishing
friendly acting Envy hot and snakes over
the next decade battling on the streets
for fun grew more popular and became a
subculture of competing rappers testing
their skills
[Music]
in the mid 90s hip-hop festivals like
Scribble Jam featured freestyle battle
competitions that would draw
up-and-coming rappers to battle for a
chance to earn Prize Money Trophies and
exposure seeing the appeal of freestyle
competitions TV networks began
incorporating rap battles into their
programming shows like HBO's Blaze
battle MTV's MC battle and BET's 106 and
Park would bring battle rap to worldwide
television
in the early 2000s Troy Mitchell better
known as smack White had begun
interviewing and filming several
established artists like 50 Cent Beanie
Siegel DMX and Cam'ron but he wasn't
just covering celebrities smack would
also film with up-and-coming east coast
rappers he would record their freestyles
and produce Indie music videos to help
promote their image and mixtapes smack
then took all of this footage and
created a DVD video magazine called
Smack DVD
I used to go around do exclusive
interviews shoot videos help them
promote their projects help them show
them in environments and places that you
won't normally see them in on a regular
standard you know TV network like mtbt
right yeah you're gonna see them in the
studios you want to see them in
airplanes in a house on a block in a
neighborhood vlogging before vlogging
was a big right that's literally what it
was heavily bootleg smack DVDs made it
to outlets all around the world and
became one of the most popular sources
for uncensored hip-hop news and music
smack began including rap battles near
the end of each volume and in keeping
with Battle Raps Origins these battles
took place in gyms barber shops and on
street corners where crowds could watch
the show I closed it off with a classic
hip-hop battle and you know it it that
that segment of the DVD got so popular
people used to body DVD with uh
mainstream artists like you know I mean
Eminem 50 Cent you know uh uh Cam'ron
Fat Joe you know Busta Rhymes you know I
had all these major artists on the front
of the DVD with major coverage of these
artists and people used to basically go
body DVD and go to the back of the DVD
first to watch the battle smack uh
literally my first experience is exactly
what you describing I'm interested like
what's all this stuff what's that no no
no skipping skipping skipping this one
we gotta see so I never even caught the
the promo the interviews with the battle
was the absolutely
meet me in person
then Worldstar came into play I didn't
think about Worldstar and they made a
killing because they wasn't into content
creation but they wasn't the traffic
absolutely absolutely so they killed me
that was a bit that that business model
was you know I mean at that time was a
success moving forward to 2000 and 2009
you know I just had to figure out like
yo what was the most valuable content
that still exists with what I was
producing and I was Battle Rap a Smack
DVD rap battles grew in popularity smack
some opportunity to create a platform
for battle rappers to perform it from
the larger crowds that's when the
ultimate rap League was born
better known as the URL the ultimate rap
League moved from the streets and began
renting venues for battle rap events to
house their growing number of fans by
2009 the URL started posting their
battles on YouTube for viewers to watch
online it was Tay Rock's seat belt
Haymaker That Shook the internet that
solidified the URL as one of the most
exciting channels to watch on YouTube
you get another cut
another cut it looked like the seat belt
won't work him down buckle up
and there are more and more battle
rappers becoming superstars in the
community like gichigani with 57 battles
on YouTube alone and over 32 million
views gichi Gotti has been url's
champion of the year for three years in
a row as battle rap culture grew online
more and more leagues started popping up
all over the world leagues like the
Canadian owned King of the DOT The Woman
Led Queen of the Ring and the Filipino
flip top
and the UK don't flop have pulled in
millions of subscribers do you consider
about a rap to be a sport yes absolutely
um yeah when I first started
representing you know um the art form of
battle rap you know I I I modeled it
after like you know I try to model it
after like the UFC you know what I'm
saying I really influenced from the UFC
look just wanted to come up with a name
that people will always remember
so now that you know how bad rap guy
started let's break down how it works a
battle is usually two competitors going
back and forth for three rounds and at
the end it's up to the audience to
decide the winner
there are several widely used forms of
wordplay but the most common are angles
schemes Haymakers and punches punches a
short for punch lines that the lines
delivered at the climax of a setup
gangbang in America extra powerful
punches are called Haymakers they're
usually accompanied by a small pause to
generate a stronger crowd reaction
I grabbed the nose running I'm coming
down with something for Flair and
creativity a battler may also use a
scheme this is when a rapper presents a
subject matter and then follows it up
with a long form parallel comparing the
subject matter to something else your
career is just like shaqs he spent four
years in a land
and then we all believed in Magic you
became lost and jealous and find out the
way to compete while a lot of battle rap
verses are written there are also
freestyles and rebuttals freestyles are
where you improvise bars on the Spy you
can reference your opponent's clothes or
anything that's happening in the moment
a rebuttal is similar but instead you
improvise bars responding to something
your opponent just said and lastly we
have angles an angle is a personal
attack that points out your opponent's
flaws angles are all about focusing on
specific things about your opponent to
break them down I saying your whack
but bro it's the same move every time
you kick that set up punch line set a
punch line that's how you split that
just a candy wrapper with four bars you
would see how easy it is
best punch lines come from with what
resonates could be so you don't want to
say something that a bunch of people
don't know about and then it's like when
you got an audience there you know they
can't pull out their phone or go to
Google and look it up so it's just about
you know reading reading the room
knowing your audience like you know on
the URL stage I'm gonna get a little
more intricate because they already
understand exactly what it is that we do
what are the differences
between a battle rap a battle rapper and
a studio rapper or what order some
common misconceptions common
misconception is uh battle rappers can't
make music
uh they they put us in this in this very
very small box you know what I'm saying
it's it's it's it's a bad stigma they
got on us they say we can't make music I
just don't understand because battle
rappers are clearly the best writers as
far as element of of being an MC you
only give one opportunity you could
never say this again you have one take
you have to wow a audience Tom and Tom
again with new materials my whole career
everything I did was a throwaway because
I can never you when if I use those bars
again I'm wrong you recycle it I'm wrong
for using My Own lyrics again so our job
is much harder even if they're not
creating chart Toppers battle rappers
still have a huge influence on popular
culture today whether it's ESPN
commercials the BET hip-hop Awards or
reality TV then there's shows like Nick
Cannon's wilding out which has taken
inspiration from Battle Rap culture and
even features URL Stars conceited
Charlie Clips and Hitman Holla
what kind of things do you see coming in
in the future for for battle rap I'm
trying to make this a a a household
sport what we have accomplished so far
is is amazing because like you know I
mean if you pay attention to what's
going on and this coach is like you know
you see so many different territories
have adopted you know the the style of
of this art form
it's an artist right it's entertainment
and um these guys have found a way to
provide for their families to entertain
us this way they put on a show for us
and that's what it's about even though
it started in the underground the sport
has become so popular that teenagers who
once dreamed of being the next big rap
artist are now dreaming of being the
next great battle rap star before you go
I want to let you know about fight the
power how hip-hop changed the world a
new PBS series hosted by hip-hop Legend
chutse it's about how hip-hop became a
global movement that spoke truth to
power check out the link in the
description below and let them know
soundfield sent you
oh